okay I've been talking for months now
about how Democrats need a platform
ideally a progressive one we can't wait
around for Trump Russia to take Trump or
the Republicans down we can't wait
around to just say hey were the anti
Trump party or candidates it's too
unpredictable the I'm not the other guy
idea motif has never really worked too
well in American politics so my advice
was progressives within the Democratic
Party need to pick three main topics
Healthcare should be number one some
amount of healthcare for all right
doesn't necessarily mean single-payer
but maybe you start with that or a
public option and negotiate - a public
option that was number one number two
we've got to make a case about the
climate and about the environment that
is not a science-based
case because we know that the deniers
don't care about the science it has to
be a case made along a patriotic
national security and nationalistic line
to try to appeal to moderates and those
on the right and number three we need
some kind of cohesive approach to this
amalgam of other issues which are
everything from immigration to race
relations and and internal problems okay
those were my sort of three suggestions
and now senator Elizabeth Warren
Democrat from Massachusetts says that
Democrats in 2018 and 2020 should
campaign on a national singer payer
healthcare plan hello
we had a guy in 2016 who believed in
that his name was Bernie Sanders and
senator Elizabeth Warren opted not to
get involved in the Democratic primary
instead supporting the eventual winner
Hillary Clinton Genk yuga recently asked
Elizabeth Warren
why didn't you support it seems like
you're close to Bernie Sanders as
politics
why didn't you support Bernie Sanders
during the primary and she gave some
bizarre unintelligible answer which we
played for you last week or the week
before and now she says hey here's an
idea
Democrats should run on single-payer
health care for the next two election
cycles here's what she said to The Wall
Street Journal a couple of days ago
quote President Obama tried to move us
forward with health care coverage by
using a conservative model
that came from one of the conservative
think tanks that had been advanced by a
Republican governor in Massachusetts
spot-on so far Elizabeth Warren now it's
time for the next step and the next step
is single-payer obviously she's right
but where was she last year Bernie
Sanders was that guy and she sat out the
primary and didn't explain why to Jen
cougar I like Elizabeth Warren we've
entered we've had her in our studio I
voted for her in Massachusetts I agree
with the undeniable fact that she's one
of the most progressive senators in the
Senate at this point when she's wrong
I've got to call her out you've got to
be kidding me here Pat there was an
opportunity for her to make that point
known in 2016 during the primary in her
defense at the time just about everyone
thought that Hillary Clinton was going
to be the Democratic nominee and maybe
Elizabeth Warren thought that had
Hillary Clinton assumed the presidency
she would have had a greater role in her
administration perhaps been able to
argue for things like universal health
care at that point it's a defense but
it's one that supports basically crony
capitalist as usual so while Pat what
Pat saying is probably true right but
it's not a defensive of the underlying
morality of the decision that she made
it's sort of a defense of the
practicality and speaking of
practicality yet you're not going to get
single-payer with a Republican house a
Republican Senate and a Republican White
House there's no doubt but stake a line
in the sand and negotiate from that and
there is a case to be made hindsight
bias is significant there's a case to be
made Obama started with maybe a public
option and negotiated to a center-right
think-tank policy from the 1990s
maybe if Obama had started with
single-payer he would have ended up
negotiating - a public option sure and I
think the time to argue for single-payer
is now it's not after the Republicans
are able to pass their abortive health
care plan and so many people lose
coverage no doubt people have to realize
that there is an alternative to the ACA
and the best one is on the left this is
a particularly good time because of the
disaster after disaster that Republicans
are proposing with these American Health
Care Act versions this is not
controversial in most of the developed
ECD countries some people will hear us
talking about this Pat and they'll say
oh my god you socialists
government takeover blah blah blah up
countries that are not socialist
countries that are our level of
development have decided hey we're going
to nationalize health care because it's
cheaper and it works better and by the
way don't just campaign on it I say
start actually trying to move it forward
whether it's HR 676 which is known as
the United States National Health Care
Act or also known as the expanded and
improved Medicare for all Act it's out
there which would establish a
single-payer system period
don't just campaign on it start working
on this issue so hey Elizabeth Warren
you're right
where were you nine months ago that's my
question today's sponsor is taga dab the
hosting specialists whatever your
hosting needs for your business or
project taga dab can do it dedicated
servers virtual private servers cloud
server solutions colocation custom
server solutions and the big thing at
taga dab is there customer support over
70% of their business comes from repeat
orders and recommendations from existing
customers this is a testament to the
great support that they give their
customers currently rated a nine point
seven out of ten according to the
Trustpilot review system with a growing
number of people interested in moving
their businesses and projects to the
cloud taga dab currently offers our
viewers and listeners a twenty british
pound free credit about twenty four US
dollars to all new customers that
sign-up gives you a chance to try the
service this is a limited availability
offer for the viewers and listeners of
the David Pakman show
to take advantage go to sign up CAG
adapt comm /t DPS and use the offer code
TDPS
20 during account registration support
our sponsors and support our show in
doing so sign up da ga da be com /t DPS
coupon code is pvps 20